what about cleaning the mouth and the
nose with water whilst one feels just
like refreshing the mouth um or in the
middle of
woodu is this a permitted act as far as
putting water in the mouth or goggling
the mouth with water or putting water in
the nose whether a person is feeling hot
or whether while doing woodoo it is
permissible because it doesn't enter the
body as long as the water doesn't enter
the body a person does not swallow the
water it's permissible and in woodoo
goggling is a requirement putting water
in the mouth is a requirement but
natural doing woodoo is f before
offering Salah and while fasting you
have to offer Salah and you have to do
Wu so how can it be prohibited so when a
person puts water in his mouth while
goggling in woodoo or otherwise he
should be careful that he does not
swallow the water and when he puts it
into the nose there are some people who
think it will break the fast based on a
Hadith and that's the reason they only
touch the water to the tip of the nose
and they don't put it inside because the
Hadith of the messenger of Allah subhana
tala and wasallam said it's mentioned in
Hadith of Abu da volume number two in
the book of fasting Hadith number 2360
that the prophet said snuff water
excessively while doing woodoo except
while fasting mm that means the prophet
recommended that you should snuff put
the water excessively in your nose
except while fasting indicating that if
the water goes through the nose into
your throat into the stomach it will
break the fast that doesn't mean putting
water in the nose is prohibited so
normally when you put water it doesn't
go into your throat and even if you
snuff excessively all way it doesn't go
it can go so it's a precaution the
prophet said that don't snuff water
excessively while fasting otherwise you
have to do that so this Hadith also
proves that putting water in the nose it
is permitted but you have to be careful
you should not snuff excessively so that
it goes into the throat otherwise if
water goes into the throat and the
stomach either VI the mouth or the nose
it will break the fast but
unintentionally while doing woodoo or
while goggling if the water does enter
inshallah Allah will not hold it
responsible because it's done
unintentionally